Here's an example of how not to do it. Say you have a nice address book
application with an address book class in it, and that class has a sort method
in it. And now you're writing some financial application that or, or
a financial part of an overall application, in which you'd like to do sorting.
And the piece you are working on has to do with ledgers, for
keeping track of credits and debits, and so on. So you'd like to,
to use the sort that's part of the address book in your ledger class. So
one strategy for doing that might merely be to have ledger be a subclass that is
inherent from address book. But this would not be an example of generalization.
An address book is not a general version of a ledger.
This would be an abuse of power. So what can you do instead?